today's episode of just getting started
with rich eisen
is brought to you by geico do you want
to rent your home sure you do
and i bet it can be hard work you know
what's easy bundling policies with geico
geico makes it easy to bundle your
homeowners or renters insurance along
with your auto policy
it's a good thing too because you
already have so much to do around your
home
go to geico.com get a quote and see how
much
you could save it's geico easy visit
geico.com today
that's geico.com
hey everybody welcome to the latest
edition of just getting started right
here on westwood one podcast
i am your humble host rich eisen and
we've got a very special
show in store for you and i know i i use
those words
uh seriously even though back in my
days of being young and watching tv
shows a little bit too much when you
would hear about a very special episode
you'd go okay yeah right
everybody says that but we've got dr
anthony fauci on this show
and as everybody who has been kind
enough
to download and or hopefully subscribe
to this podcast over the first month
plus you realize
that uh the show is mostly about pulling
out
something for you to take with you uh on
your journey
if you need to just get started on
something new or just get
started on a life path that you've
always
wanted to take based on circumstances
with a pandemic or something else
um pulling out somebody's origin story
whether it's an academy award winner
like matthew mcconaughey or
a an entrepreneur and a very successful
businessman and
and uh best-selling author and damon
john
or a best-selling novelist and last week
harlan coven we had soledad o'brien on
as well
it's been mostly geared towards the
business world or
your own spiritual wellness
trying to just get started on something
today we're going to just delve directly
right into the pandemic
and i've got a bunch of questions for dr
anthony fauci not only in how
he got started on his life path but
about how we can all get
started on getting back to life as
normal with the
covet 19 pandemic now over a year old
and vaccinations in this country in the
united states now
uh coming up close to a half year of
existence
and um and that whole process
the way it is going and how we if you
are fully vaccinated
can go about your business how we if you
are
unvaccinated can go about your business
and why you should get the vaccine
so we can all get back to business and
life is normal
he is a director of the united states
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases
and the chief medical advisor to the
president of the united states honored
and pleased to have uh here on just
getting started dr anthony fauci dr
fauci thanks for the time i greatly
appreciate it
good to be with you thank you for having
me you bet how does
one become an immunologist how does one
become why did you get started on this
path
dr fauci well you know it was just my
my interest in medicine in general and
as i began studying medicine i got very
interested
in the relationship between the body's
defenses against infection
and the actual infections that
historically have been
you know shaping civilizations over the
centuries so
infectious disease and immunology is a
very exciting field if you look at the
impact
that infections have had on civilization
you know from smallpox to measles to
polio
to the plague it's just a very exciting
and gratifying field so when you
got started was there somebody who gave
you a big leg up was there i guess if
you will a breakthrough
for you back in the day dr fauci
no it really wasn't um i i had
originally started out thinking i wanted
to just practice medicine
in new york city i i did my training in
medical school in new york city
at the new york hospital cornell medical
center which is now wild cornell
and i came down to the nih here in
bethesda
which is you know the largest research
institution in the world
to study the combination of infectious
diseases
and immunology and it was my
fellowship here for three years that
really
turned me on and caught my interest in
wanting
to do clinical research in the context
of infectious diseases and then things
really
you know turned around for me in 1981
when we had the first cases of what
would turn out to be
hiv aids and that's really been my main
area of interest and research for the
last 40 years
i've been involved in as the director of
the institute i've been involved in
all of the outbreaks including pandemic
flu
and ebola and zika and chikungunya
and things like that but what we're
going through right now with kova 19
really is unprecedented in its impact
so it started off a long time ago with
hiv aids as
an emerging infection and worked its way
up to here we are right now with
probably the biggest public health
challenge that we faced in over 100
years so
what what prepared you for
the toughest moments
for you over the last year plus was
there anything that you can
recall that would that that set the
stage for you to
meet the moment as best you could over
the last
year plus dr fauci you know there isn't
one single thing rich
it is sort of a gradual accumulation of
both experience
um and capability um
you know when we first uh i would think
the early years of
of hiv aids was probably the thing that
prepares you for the unfolding
of an outbreak that you know very little
about
in the first days weeks months and then
as the weeks
and months go by you learn more and more
and you realize
unfortunately with this particular
outbreak
how much worse it was than you could
have imagined
uh that preparation for me began 40
years ago
when i devoted most of my activities
to addressing that disease which was
brand new and mysterious at the time
which was hiv aids which is now we know
a lot about it we have
excellent therapies for it even though
it still is a global
challenge nonetheless a person
at least in our world who gets diagnosed
and gets on an appropriate regimen of
therapy can live essentially a normal
life that was very different
than in the early years 1981 1981-2345
when i was taking care of desperately
ill
persons with hiv at a time when almost
all of them were dying i mean it was
almost 100 percent mortality
to see that transformed with the
development of drugs into a disease that
people can now almost live an early a
normal life
that was sort of my baptism of fire in
dealing with outbreaks such as what
we're dealing with right now
so uh is there a through line uh
of the presidents that you've served
under a certain
um a certain i guess
character uh of the presidents that you
served under that
that you've noticed part of this podcast
is about leadership
and part of this podcast is about you
know people
trying to get started on their lives
that might have been upended by this
pandemic but
have you noticed anything of that nature
throughout
they're all different i mean i have had
the privilege
of serving directly and being advisory
to
seven presidents starting with ronald
reagan
and going right up through george h.w
bush
president clinton george w bush
president obama
president trump and now president joe
biden
they're all different but it's so it's
fascinating
and and understandable how their
presidency is often shaped by the
circumstances within which their
presidency exists
i mean if you look at each different
president has different challenges
i mean in the very beginning uh ronald
reagan
who was a very popular president that
was the early years when
hiv first emerged and
he you know very many people feel
understandably that he was a very an
excellent president
but one of the things that he's his
legacy is
sort of tainted by was he didn't respond
as aggressively as he could have to the
early years of hiv
he could have used the bully pulpit of
the presidency
to call attention to this emerging
plague
george h.w bush one of the finest
gentlemen that i've ever met
he got it and started to really put
support and and resources to studying
hiv
and then when we got to clinton that got
even better
you know george w bush started the
pepfar
program which was the president's
emergency plan for aids relief which
you know really has now resulted in the
saving of
about 14 to 15 million lives most people
don't appreciate
that accomplishment on his part of
creating a system where you could treat
care for and prevent
hiv infection in the developing world
but that's something that will be a very
positive part of his
legacy you know and obama had a lot of
challenges if you look at my field of
infectious diseases
you know we had pandemic flu we had
ebola we had zika
we had all of those things and then the
last year of the trump
administration was dominated by the
coven 19
which you know clearly impacted greatly
the entire planet but also
very likely had an important impact on
the outcome
of his of his presidential reelection
well and then that's one thing i want to
ask you dr fauci
is the
i guess your reaction to
that sometimes we as americans need to
have
somebody famous affected by
an infectious disease before we take it
seriously
i would say hiv and aids magic johnson
and him acquiring
and obviously when
tom hanks became infected with covet 19
rudy goldberg of the nba uh
made the nba pause i'm wondering
you as an infectious diseases uh
doctor and a leader globally what do you
think of that sometimes we
as americans or maybe globally need that
to wake up to use a phrase
what do you think you're absolutely
correct
um things don't settle into people's
mind
as being real until it
affects something that they can directly
relate to you're absolutely right with
magic
johnson but even before then you might
remember
that aids was felt to be something that
was somebody else's problem then when
rock
hudson got infected and actually died
of hiv aids it became clear that
anyone and everyone who was in a
particular risk category
could actually get infected and
ultimately die
so that was a big eye-opener for people
uh probably magic johnson was
the most dramatic of that because he was
a beloved
person uh and a heterosexual man
uh a healthy uh superstar athlete
and when he got infected that's when
everyone said oh my goodness you know
anyone could get infected if their
practice a certain type of risk behavior
um so it was really a very very
important
uh that situation i mean i was just
talking to
uh some of the people who are actually i
do put it doing a documentary
on on magic is that you know he stepped
down from the nba
and then came back remember and uh
i was i was um i really didn't want to
see him step down because i wanted him
to make it clear that
you know he could very well continue on
his professional career
um and even though he was living with
hiv
and that's why when he came back i felt
very good about that because that really
said that people can if they're properly
cared for
essentially get back to normal existence
and he was a good example
and is even to this day i mean he's a
highly successful entrepreneur and
businessman
yeah and arthur rash obviously passing
away too but
does it disappoint you does it uh get
you frustrated
um that that we sometimes need to
have that happen to someone famous in
order for us to take seriously something
you know to be so serious
that the seriousness needs to be grasped
nationally and
internationally a lot faster
yes that's a very good point uh rich
often when you're dealing
with outbreaks of this part people have
i don't know whether it's a
self-protective
mechanism to say well that can't happen
to me
that's somebody else's problem and then
when you see it happen to
a person that you can relate to you
realize
that it could be close to home for you
i i mean we're we're having a very
difficult
situation of messaging with covid19
because you know most young healthy
people if they do get infected
not always but if they do get infected
they generally have mild symptoms and
don't have the high risk of a severe
outcome
that either an elderly person or someone
with an underlying medical condition
would have that really
gives a distortion of what the ultimate
impact
of this terrible pandemic is as you know
540 plus
thousand people in the united states
have already died
from this and there are still some
people who take it lightly
who think it's nothing special in fact
there are some people who even think
that
this is a hoax it's fake news it's not
real
that's really astounding that that's the
case but there are some people not
not just a trivial number who don't
really take it
very seriously because they don't think
it's going to necessarily
impact them until it does and then it's
too late
today's episode of just getting started
is brought to you by netsuite
if you're a business owner you might be
making running your business
harder on yourself than necessary stop
paying for multiple systems that don't
give you the information
you need when you need it ditch the
spreadsheets and all the old software
you've outgrown
now is the time to upgrade to netsuite
by oracle the world's
number one cloud business system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control over your financials
hr inventory e-commerce and more
everything you need
all in one place instantaneously whether
you're doing a million or hundreds of
millions in revenue
save time and money with netsuite join
the over 24
000 companies using netsuite right now
let netsuite show you how they'll
benefit your business with a free
product tour
at netsuite.com eisen so schedule your
free product tour
right now at netsuite.com eisen that's
netsuite.com e-i-s-e-n
netsuite.com eisen now back to my
conversation with dr anthony fauci
[Applause]
why do you think there's a messaging
issue with vaccines right now
as we turn the page to the the way out
um why do you think that that is an
issue
dr fauci you know it's a complicated
situation it
isn't you know a unidimensional issue or
monolithic in the sense
of there's one reason why there's
hesitancy and anybody
who has hesitancy about a vaccine comes
at it from
the same perspective that's just not the
case
there are some fundamental there are
people who are fundamentally
anti-vaccine period no matter what
that's really a very small minority of
the group
there are others that have various
reasons to be hesitant i think the one
that we've dealt with a fair amount is
minorities namely brown and black people
african americans
who understandably have skepticism about
it because
federally run medical programs
historically if you go back in history
have not really treated brown and black
people well you know going back to the
uh very shameful uh
episode of the tuskegee experiments
decades and decades ago
which even though most of the
african-americans today were not
born at the time that the tuskegee
experiments
took place yet that was been passed down
from generation to generation about
not trusting federally
directed medical programs so the way we
overcome that is to respect
the fact that brown and black people
have skepticism and don't just blow it
off and say
you know we can understand why you have
skepticism
but you need to understand that in
today's world
there are ethical guidelines and ethical
constraints
that would make something like
that shameful episode of tuskegee
never ever been able to happen again
once you do that then you could start
addressing
some of the real concerns that they have
they think well maybe
the vaccine was developed too quickly um
and maybe it was careless maybe we
rushed it maybe corners were cut
but that's not the case because the
speed with which
the vaccines were developed was a
reflection
of the extraordinary advances that had
been made in biomedical research
and vaccine platform technology over the
previous
few decades once you get that
spoken and discussed it is gratifying to
see
how many people turn around and say you
know i understand now
i'm not being uh skeptical anymore i'll
be willing to go ahead and take the
vaccine
the thing that i don't understand very
well that i don't i don't even know how
we can counter this
is when people according to political
lines decide they don't want to get
vaccinated you know
it's surveys show that you know 30
percent or more of republicans
don't feel they want to get vaccinated
with the covert 19 vaccination
this is not a political issue so it
doesn't really make any sense
that someone according to their
political persuasion
don't want to get vaccinated that really
is
is strange i think in fact it goes along
with the strangeness
of wanting to wear a mask or not relates
to whether
you know you're on one side of the
political spectrum or the other
which again you should separate
public health matters completely from
political considerations but
that's not been the case over the last
year with covert 19.
so perhaps maybe if i can offer a couple
cents as a fully vaccinated individual
my wife and i
got two shots of the pfizer um
a couple months ago after we volunteered
and it was an amazing day volunteering
in
the the septuagenarian and octogenarians
and
who were first in line and getting that
that shot they were honking their horns
as we were
directing them to a 15-minute wait line
or a 30-minute wait line and it really
was
it was just uh invigorating just to see
this in person
um and we we received a shot at the end
of the day and so we're fully vaccinated
but quite frankly and we
we pay attention to the news and we're
attuned to what you say quite a bit dr
fauci
we don't know what we're able to do are
we able to go to indoor dining for
instance or what
what are we or what is a fully
vaccinated person
able to do now that they were not able
to do over the last
year plus yeah well that's a great
question
uh rich and the cdc has come out with
the first
installment of recommendations and
guidelines what fully vaccinated people
can do and over the coming weeks and
months they will be
coming up with more and more guidelines
the first thing
is that if you have fully vaccinated
people
in the setting of the home
can now clearly interact without masks
can have physical contact can hug do
whatever you
want to do even if you have a
person who is not vaccinated in the home
setting
with vaccinated people so long as that
unvaccinated person doesn't have an
underlying condition
that would put them at risk for a severe
outcome
then you could interact together without
masks
you could have physical contact you know
one of the things that specifically is
the example
what about grandma who gets vaccinated
can she visit her daughter and her
granddaughter
who have not been vaccinated and the
answer is
absolutely yes so long as the daughter
and the granddaughter
do not have an underlying condition that
if they wind up getting infected
that they could get a serious outcome in
other words are they normal
healthy people the questions that need
to be addressed
now that the cdc is trying to gain
enough data to make a scientifically
based recommendation is what can
fully vaccinated people do with travel
with the workplace with houses of
worship
i think until they come out with
guidelines we would need to use some
common sense
about what risks we're willing to take
so for example
the reason you don't hear saying well
you can go out and
go in any restaurant you want and do
indoor dining and things like that
because that's going to depend on the
level of infection in the community
if the level of infection in community
is very low you can be much more
flexible
on the kinds of things you can do but
right now just
yesterday there were over 50 000 new
infections
in the country that's a very high
baseline level of infection
so i think the combination of more
people getting vaccinated
and the level of infection on a daily
basis
getting lower and lower will then make
it much
easier and safer for you and i and i'm
doubly vaccinated too
for you and i to start doing things that
we were a bit reluctant to do before
like dining theater and things like that
what do you think of of sporting teams
and sporting venues
opening up indoor seating the miami heat
in particular have
uh come up with a concept of a
vaccinated section like a vaccinated
section in a
non-vaccinated section do you support
that would you
are you fine with something like that or
you're still concerned
on that you know i don't like to pass
judgment about being fine or not because
then
it gets taken out of context almost like
i've made
a recommendation for the country and and
i don't want to get ahead of the cdc
in their recommendations but i can make
some general statements
sure let's take outdoor i mean i believe
that you know every day
we're getting two to three million
people vaccinated
we already right now have over 40
million
people are fully vaccinated in the
country and 80 plus million
have already received at least one
vaccination
as we start getting into the spring
and early summer i believe you're going
to start
seeing in the outdoor ballparks of the
national the
major league baseball you're going to be
seeing
seating where you have people in the
stands up like
unlike last year where there was
essentially nobody in the stands
you're going to start seeing
incrementally increased
numbers of people that are allowed in
the stands
indoors a bit different you know you
made some proposals that are not
unreasonable
about as long as you get good
ventilation people masked and people may
be segregated and
that doesn't seem like a bad idea of
having
places where people who are vaccinated
could go i think that would be
not so bad i wouldn't want to make a
determination on that
i'd leave that to the cdc but as we get
further and further week by week month
by month
as we get into the summer i believe that
you're going to start seeing a rather
significant
uh progression towards normality with
regard to what sports
can do both indoors and outdoors what
about
dr fauci um you know and i know this
question
might be going a little bit too far down
the road as you're still looking for
arms to put or look at some point you
might be looking for arms to put
vaccines into
uh sometime this summer maybe or if not
sooner than that
um i don't want to put words in your
mouth so if you want to answer that as
part of the question that's fine but
uh do i have to and do people who get
vaccinated now have to get it again
is this going to be like a flu shot
every year hey go get your flu shot go
get your covet 19
shot is that the way this is going to be
for all of us
in the future here you know rich a
commonly asked question that we don't
have a definitive answer for because we
don't know
yet how long this immunity this
protection
lasts because this is new uncharted
territory for us this is the first
year and it has not even been a full
year
since we started vaccinating people
so we don't know whether it's going to
last a year or two or three
we know for sure that we have at least
six to eight months experience so it's
going to be at least
six months and you know as another month
or two go by it'll be eight months but
right now
the people who got vaccinated six months
ago
when you followed them they appear to
have continued immunity it probably will
wane off a bit but we don't know how far
down it'll
go so the honest and transparent
and humble answer to your question is we
don't know
but we're going to find out for sure how
do you
i mean just just by following people i
mean you know we vaccinated now
you know tens of millions of people the
people who were in the original vaccine
trial
the fisa trial had forty four thousand
people the mordarana
trial had thirty thousand people the j
and j
trial had forty thousand people those
people are going to be followed for up
to two years
so you will know how long a level of
immunity lasts
and then we'll be able to definitively
answer your question
so what's your best guess on i got a 12
year old a 10 year old seven-year-old
how when when do they get potentially
or need to get a vaccine no good
question so the studies are being done
now in all of those age groups
so since children are vulnerable
you have vulnerable to the safety of the
vaccine because you don't want to be
putting something
into the arms of children unless you are
sure
that it's safe and effective in normal
adults and then you want to test it in
children gradually
to make sure it's safe having said that
by the time we get to the early fall
it is felt that we will have enough
information to be able to vaccinate high
school students
when you talk about younger than that
twelve
to nine nine to six six to two years
six months to two years it is felt that
the the studies that we're doing
we will get enough information by the
end of this calendar year
and the very beginning of the first
quarter of 2022.
so if your younger children likely will
be vaccinated
by the end of the year the beginning of
next year the child that's going into
high school
likely by the fall and so my kids
currently again
uh second grade fourth grade sixth grade
when they're through college wha how are
they are we still living with this
you know i mean what's your best guess
is to
how you know this
this stays that's a lack
okay rich it's a great question i mean
it's a question everybody's asking
and the answer is again we don't know
but let me tell you
the things that will determine it so
when you have a global pandemic like
we're having now
you've got to have a global response
what do i mean by that
so if we get almost all people
vaccinated
in this country we get you know 70 85
percent of the people vaccinated
many of the people will have been
infected so they'll have immunity anyway
so you get a really good veil of
protection
in this country in other countries the
european union the uk
australia canada they do that that would
be really good
but to answer your question what then
happens as long as there's
disease and infection circulating
anywhere in the world it's a threat to
everywhere
in the world so that's the reason why
we've got to take
seriously the idea of making sure that
there's vaccine available
throughout the world because if you have
a raging
degree of infection in southern
africa or in asia or in the caribbean
it's always going to be a threat to the
united states to canada
to australia etc so it is conceivable if
we do it right
that we could crush this to the point
where we don't have to worry about it
ever again
if we don't do it on a global level it
could linger
so that we have to keep worrying about
perhaps revaccinating people
every year or every few years that's
entirely possible
if we don't suppress it throughout the
world
so then as i wrap up with you here dr
fauci uh and this could potentially
dovetail
into um making sure everyone understands
that because the vaccines came up so
quickly it's not because
uh you know don't forget that there were
years upon years upon years of research
that got everybody prepared for this
moment
to come up with these vaccines how
prepared are we for another
god forbid how how prepared are we for
for the next if there is one dr fauci
well if if we do lessons learned rich we
will be much better prepared there was
so many things
that could have been done better you
know the ability to get testing off the
ground quickly
that's one thing also we really need to
strengthen our local public health
infrastructure which has over the
decades
really undergone a lot of attrition so
for example the ability to do
identification isolation and contact
tracing we did not do that very well at
all
we also need to build a global health
security network
where you have communication
transparency
cooperation and collaboration among all
countries of the world
so that when something comes up you know
about it quickly
you can act on it quickly and you learn
immediately
really what the characteristics of the
outbreak is that did not happen in the
first
weeks to a month of this outbreak in
china
so there are a lot of things that we've
got to have lessons
learned which i hope we have the
corporate memory to benefit from that
i guess and then i've asked every one of
my guests on this show and again it's
been uh mostly attuned to getting people
through
uh through whatever they've gotten
through over the last year with the
pandemic mostly
um to try and just get started on their
lives once again
for people who are absolutely frightened
about what happened over the last year
even if they haven't lost a loved one
how do you tell everybody to just get
started on their lives
normally yeah dealing with this
situation
you know that's great yeah that's a
great question because that's something
we're going to have to face
soon i think people should understand
that this is going to end it really will
there is so much frustration we've been
living i know i have and i'm sure so
many other people
kind of a surrealistic existence over
the last year where your
entire life has been upended some more
than
others this is going to end we're going
to get it under control
and we will get back to normal so your
advice to people is just
hang in there a bit longer don't get
discouraged
it's going to end vaccines are going to
be the end
game answer to this when we get enough
people vaccinated
it's going to turn this around very
dramatically so just
hang in there keep pulling with it it's
going to be okay
same thing to you you hang in there you
have i will
i mean this has probably been quite the
journey for you over the last year in
your family
uh as well so um thank you
for everything that you have done i
appreciate it rich thank you for having
me on your show
i appreciate that man when we're through
all this maybe we can talk about who's
the greatest athlete in the history of
holy cross
you were bob cousy
it's got to be the cruz all the way well
i can't wait to talk about such uh such
things with you dr fauci thanks for
being here on just getting started
thank you take care good to be with you
well that was pretty cool
that was just all kinds of awesome dr
anthony fauci is someone who i've
admired throughout this entire process
speaking truth
when it's very difficult for many of us
to hear it is
it's difficult it's very very difficult
and i've also seen
some of the responses that i've received
on twitter since
i announced that dr fauci was going to
be on this program
and how many people feel that the way
that he's talked about the virus
or his belief system on how to handle
the virus is been steeped in something
other than the science
and i hope uh his appearance on this
show
disabuses anyone of that notion he's
clearly
about throughout his entire remarkable
career
the public health and everybody's health
and making sure that the science rules
the day
and i do hope again that anybody out
there
who might be hesitant to get the vaccine
for whatever reason
hearing this podcast doesn't take it um
in anything other than the proper spirit
of wanting everyone to be healthy that
you take the vaccine
as soon as you possibly can and
again i'll just tell the story that my
wife and i
here you know in southern california
one day went and volunteered at a mass
vaccination site in southern california
and
spent the day waving cars
from the vaccination point where they
got the shots in the arms
through the window provided by nurses
and members of the los angeles county
public health department
and i remember just being there it was
cold it's chilly out
even for southern california and um
we're standing there my wife um
and i and others that we met
standing at um the
end of the parking lot where
cars either had to go to a 30-minute
wait or a 15-minute wait based on what
they told
the nurses when they got the shot if
they have ever had
some sort of a side effect from any
vaccine any shot in their lives
so those who are concerned about maybe
getting
a side effect from the vaccine would be
sent to the 30-minute
spot and others who
[Music]
didn't have that concern sent to the
15-minute spot and they had a sign in
the window that was placed in there
on their dashboard by one of the nurses
as to which line they should go so
somebody like me or my wife
would know to wave them to the 15-minute
line of the 30-minute line
and just to see the looks on the faces
of
and it was mostly the elderly because
again this was early on in the process
when
there was a very small subset
of people who were allowed to get the
vaccine
just seeing the look on the faces of
these
people who were in their 70s and 80s
or had some sort of underlying condition
that required them to get the shot on
that day and just seeing the look of
relief
and the honking of the horns and the
pumping of the fists
was awesome there's no other way to put
it other than just
simply awesome and um
we got into it and it was a sense of
community in a sense of
excitement and a sense of
optimism that my wife and i had not
felt in months in a long time
and the only sense of community
that i could equate this to that i ever
felt was volunteering in
southern manhattan lower manhattan after
9 11
making sure that first responders were
getting fed or needed
some food or drink or clothes collecting
clothes for those
who needed it and doling out
all sorts and all manners of supplies
and even though it was a horrible time
there was a sense of we're all pulling
together for the greater good and we're
going to get through this together there
was a sense
of it and the vaccine made us feel that
way
and then getting stuck later in the day
um as there were leftover vaccines my
wife and i were
all over it and um we didn't have any
side effects it was the pfizer
and um for anyone who's wondering we had
no side effects
and just the sense that we both had that
as our children were were going to go
back to school as
we were going about our lives
trying to seek out any normalcy the fact
that we got vaccinated
was incredible and
i i understand people may be hesitant or
concerned
that who knows maybe months from now
i'll be regretting saying this on just
getting started about the vaccine
because we'll learn
something about it i'm i'm not one of
those people
i hope you're not and that you do trust
the science
and trust the people who are saying that
they would never
administer something like this even if
there was a shadow of a doubt
of there being something overly
concerning
and you know i'm all for
somebody like the miami heat or other
sports organizations
saying hey there's a fully vaccinated
section
and you only get to you know if you're
from the same family sit together
and you'll be a couple of seats apart
from somebody else who's fully
vaccinated
and let's go and cheer for your team
from a very nice seat
um i i i hope that doesn't last too long
because i want to get back to normal
seeing all these march madness games as
we're culminating that uh turn
as the tournament is as uh behind us now
uh missing the crowd getting ready for
another major league baseball season i'm
gonna be heading to the nfl draft at the
end of the month for nfl network
the fact that i'm fully vaccinated gives
me a self-confidence
and a level of excitement that i haven't
felt in a while
i just wanted to say those things as we
appreciate dr fauci being on the show
next week we return a little bit more to
the
business side of things gary vaynerchuk
the one
and only um entrepreneur
businessman and um best-selling author
and somebody who gives tremendous advice
to folks who are wondering how to just
get started
so tune in next week and we'll see you
on the next edition of just getting
[Music]
[Applause]
started
you